good evening friends tonight from truest
park in atlanta georgia it's game one of
the national league championship series
between the braves and the dodgers max
freed gets the ball for atlanta and he
faces corey knobles the dodgers will be
going with a bullpen game max freed and
he has been a postseason performer the
last couple of years he's been excellent
well you see his second half stats but
if you think about what he did in his
last 12 starts
he was 8-0 era under two two up two down
there's a swing in the ground ball base
hit into right center pass and diving
ozzy alvey's
now seeger's going to try to stretch it
into a double and he does and it's a
hustle double for corey seeger runner in
second two down three brings the 2-2 to
turner check swing believe he went he
did yes sir
struck him out
and that ends the
[Applause]
it's an opener again and it's the same
opener from georgetown texas cory knebel
gets the ball in back-to-back games he
started four games as an opener during
the regular season of course game five
and rosario leads it off with the braves
and he slings one into right field base
hit
rosario aggressive turn he'll stop there
with bets recovering and it's a lead off
single and now the freddie chance
raining down early runner goes swinging
a miss throwing a second and the tag
safe the naval is a pitcher you can run
on and rosario got a great jump it is a
strikeout freeman is gone but rosario
into second base rosario goes to third
two don austin reilly coming up that's
going to get away from smith
and
in the score rosario
brave strike first smith couldn't corral
that fastball from knebel
and atlanta on the board first in game
one of the nlcs one two hung on and
missed strike three change up breaking
ball and the inning is over two up and
two down that'll bring up aj pollock
first ball swinging aj pollock a liner
into right center that's down and to the
wall
peterson unable to run it down and aj
pollock
a double into right center field back to
back innings with two out doubles for
the dodgers chris taylor now
full count pelican second
and a swing and a shot into left center
field to base hit pollock will head home
he will score
and chris taylor with a two out rbi
single and the dodgers right away tie
this one up in the second inning bring
steven souza jr to the plate he's pinch
hitting for the pitcher spot 3-2 the
pitch on the way
get him looking strike three
fastball at 95 pin to the outside corner
next up for the dodgers it is phil
bickford not a spring training game this
is game one of the nlcs but it has that
feel a pitcher and ending two and two to
jack peterson a swing adam is bickford
strikes him out that slider there's tua
one ball two strikes to count on darno
and dowdy goes bickford puts them away
three up three down with two k's so
turner first in the lcs for him and a
man on with one way here in the third
inning turner at first
little jam shot swats in his back only
shoulder catch
he got a great jump on that ball justin
turner struck out of the first inning
sends one here to right field here
coming over jack peterson and jack runs
this one down right into the fire just
added to the nlcs roster justin bruhl
two outs now to the top of the order and
rosario on the ground shift is on
[Applause]
and the plan is working for the dodgers
will smith pop the short in his first
at-bat stepping in and smith sends one
of the air deep left field that is way
back and will smith strikes again
his third home run of the post season
two to one dodgers as smith goes deep
will smith has given the dodgers a two
to one lead freed oh and two on pollock
and down he goes free comes back nasty
slider that time third strikeout for max
free got him to swing and miss for
strike three so it'll be tony gosling
now coming out of the dodger bullpen
ronnie he has been a starter
mostly this season with the dodgers has
not pitched since september
30th i'm still trying to get over the
two different tongues
on his spikes yeah it's a cat fur too
two gone in the atlanta fourth inning
now for austin reilly the milwaukee
brewers featured lots of sliders against
riley in that first series they lived
away and riley rips one
left field line it is a
home run
riley
ties it a two riley drove one right on
down the line that thing just went off
the grid
two two game here at the bottom of the
fourth inning
of the board with the lead-off hit
mookie betts is flying to right twice
tonight a shot right to
all these and a double play well you
couldn't have a better positioning set
up there mookie benson it right on the
nose but on the ground green set turner
leads from second
[Applause]
fastball right at the bottom of the zone
and a huge strikeout for max three
that's his fifth in the ball game so two
men are out runner at third now and that
brings up aj pollock and pollock a line
shot caught by albies
ending over and a huge play by ozzy
albees to wrap up the top of the sixth
inning jesse will be the second
different left-hander batting average
against 1 26 against vessel this summer
one away freddy freeman in a 2-2 count
and a swing at him as vessia strikes him
out and three strikeouts for freddie two
up two down the two one all these little
half swing got a hurry
and no chance albies will reach
infield hit and albies will get riley to
the plate a swing at a miss
vessel strikes him out challenged him
well max freed is done brian stitcher
pulls the plug on a starter 81 pitches
six innings
two runs he gives up no walks and five
k's and now tyler matic is on out of the
bullpen little flare gonna be trouble
and
freddie freeman cannot make the play
and taylor on his way to second with a
hustle double
taylor right out of the box was thinking
two freeman almost came up with a
miraculous catch
but it goes as a double in the dodgers
in business in the seventh his second
hit of the game four straight innings
the leadoff hitter has reached for la
and the dodgers with a runner at third
base and one out mookie bets the batter
dodgers threatening to take the lead
here in inning number seven and bets in
the air he popped it up foul territory
freeman with room two outs
i gotta go through trey turner matic
deals a swing at a miss he struck him
out
wow what a job
slider fans turner and in a 2-2 game in
the eighth inning it is the dodger
closer ken lee jansen on to work similar
scenario to game five vince hitter is a
adrianza down he goes
a strikeout for kenley janssen two up
and two down
ground ball right side justin turner
with the shift on picks it up and throws
him out and janssen is perfect in the
eighth will smith braves closer enters
this one at a 2-2 tie in the ninth one
away here's aj pollock in the air
late on it
pop-up to freeman
two outs a two-out walk the go-ahead run
is on now
and here comes cody bellinger for los
angeles
here he comes and a swing and a base hit
in the right
taylor turns heads to third now he's
stopped now he's in a run down throw the
forward riley will chase him taylor on
his way back and now it's swanson and
the inning is over
and the bad base running takes him out
of the ninth inning what in the world
chris taylor was thinking about the old
cardinal rule you don't want to make the
first down or the third out at third
base
and taylor caught in the rundown and
that ends the inning blake trinen
is on the mound ninth inning
2-2 game the braves have the winning run
standing at first base one down for
austin reilly takes off
throwing a second
stolen base
what a jump
before stepper no chance for will smith
and now the braves have the winning run
at second base
slug down to left field and this is down
for a basement here comes ozzie and the
braves take game
what an one
opening act in game one
of the 2021 national league championship
series and the braves win it three to
two
austin riley tied it with a home run in
the fourth he wins it with a single in
the ninth his first career walk off rbi
for riley regular or postseason and
austin reilly this magical season and
he's got one more piece to add to it
right here
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes